and finally new rule now that it's been
a month since I gave the commencement
address at Berkeley
someone has to check in with the people
who tried to have my speech cancelled
and make sure they made it through okay
also since they were protesting me for
once saying that Islam is quote the only
religion that acts like the Mafia and
will kill you if you say the wrong Viger
draw the wrong picture and then two
jihadists gunned down twelve people in
Paris for saying the wrong thing and
drawing the wrong picture you have to
tell me where do I go to protest you
the March we saw in Paris last Sunday
with the leaders of 44 countries
standing up for free speech was very
heartening but unfortunately not
everybody got the memo like the Pope and
his American vigilante bill donohue
Bill's the head of the Catholic League
and as such he's called me an
anti-catholic bigots so many times it's
not my ringtone bill also once took
umbrage at my stance on pedophilia I'm
against it and threatened to I guess
this is a Catholic thing now punch me in
the nose because whether you're
representing the Prince of Peace or the
religion of peace threatening violence
is a great way to drive home the point
that you're secure and your medieval
believes last week mr. Donohue wrote
that it was too bad Charlie Hebdo spaw
sure quote didn't understand the role he
played in his tragic death which is like
saying the rape victim didn't understand
that her clothes were too provocative
and that's the great irony of Bill
Donohue he's a staunch advocate for a
religion which considers masturbation as
sin and yet he's a huge jerk-off
glenn greenwald says anti-muslim speech
like the cartoons in Sharlee are a quote
vital driver in bombing and occupying
Muslim countries and killing the
innocent really
newspaper cartoons did all that until
they get to the horoscopes in the
crossword it reminds me of one of the
protest signs I saw up at Berkeley last
month it said Islamophobia kills does it
the phobia kills or maybe maybe more
it's the ak-47 and the beheadings and
the planes into buildings anyway Wow
really you don't agree with that
okay thank you thank you hey one guy
thank you
you think someone like Glenn Greenwald
wouldn't be so ambivalent about
terrorism since terrorism is really just
bullying extreme bullying and I thought
we hated bullying now when it happens in
high school these days people go nuts
when I was a kid
adults just shrugged and let our kids
are [ __ ] what are you gonna do
yeah liberals hate bullying all right
but they're not opposed to using it when
they casually throw out words like
bigoted and racist it does cow people
into avoiding this debate and if you're
doing that you don't get to where
there's just we Sharlee button the
button you should wear says just we part
of the problem and that goes for
everybody this may surprise you but I am
NOT a big fan of Rush Limbaugh however
if you're one of the people with a
website devoted to making him go away
you are part of the problem and
ironically you're not even a proper
liberal because you don't get free
speech you're just a
they're just a baby who can't stand to
live in the world where you hear things
that upset you oh you're not alone in
much of Europe denying the Holocaust is
a crime it shouldn't be the French
arrested an anti-semitic comedian this
week for his comments about the attack
which were vile but opinions shouldn't
be illegal everyone can always come up
everyone can always come up with a
reason why the thing that bugs you
should get a waiver but free speech only
works if there are no waivers no waivers
including for religion like say you are
and I'm just picking a religion at
random here Muslim and you love love
love you some Islam it's what uplifts
you and inspires you and you can't
imagine your life without it or why
everyone else doesn't love it too
believe me I get that that's how I feel
about weed but when someone criticizes
weed I think good more for me not off
with their head and as a comedian I like
it that jokes can hurt I like it that
Kim jong-un was wounded by a movie if
you're a satirist that's winning
Kim's young gun hates jokes he doesn't
get them and he takes them too seriously
which proves something I've always
suspected about him he's a lesbian